elle
[Musique]
maintenant que tu vis à l'autre bout de
paris
quand une changé d'âge tut havre un long
voyage
vient me dire
bonjour au coin de la rue du four
je viens visiter
hassan
m
plus
je suis l'image d'un quartier et gréco
ce saint germain des prés saint germain
des prés c'est l'existentialisme le
presser les années 50
jamal est prêt c'est
ça tourne autour de quelques personnages
dont je suis finalement ça jamais les
clés pour vous c'est ça a été les cuves
des jours c'est un oui on s'est vraiment
apprécié les légumes déjà d'une part et
d'autre part ça a été
bon si je n'avais pas rencontré les gens
que je rencontrais je n'aurais jamais pu
être ce que je suis aujourd'hui
j'ai été très gâté j'ai été très
privilégié papa par l'argent on part par
la rencontre je marchais et puis je
regardais dans les cafés la première les
vues j'ai vu le floor où ils avaient
l'air de faire très chaud hein je
regardais pourrait déjà entrer sortir
c'est assez fascinant et puis un jour
pourquoi tout à coup un endroit dans le
monde devient le creuset le creuset
comme ça de tout de tout
toutes les pensées brusquement tout le
monde le monde entier le moment' et
s'est retrouvé là pourquoi parce que ces
gens-là dérangeait peut-être déranger un
certain ordre établi au nom d'un
défoulement non mais non c'était
simplement le crime le fait de joie
c'était vive la liberté c'était la
liberté retrouvée c'était le bonheur
c'était la liberté d'expression excepté
la libération de tous l'opération se
parlent d'un coup c'était c'était vrai
c'était la libération
et les gens les gens disent bonjour il
ya des dames qui passent des dames qui
avaient averti depuis très très
longtemps et qui quand on se rend compte
sur le trottoir me disent on est bien
content de vous avoir dans le quartier
ça nous fait plaisir
geo gréco et lainage c'est l'image qui
est reçu par les gens c'est entre gréco
et moyenne distance
les gens sont dits oui elle dans la
troisième personne se prend pour de
gaulle la mena
non je me prends vraiment justement pour
rien ne prouve pas grand chose
je dirais qu la vie pour vous cela
semble une quête d'une quatrième
heureuse mais de quoi de qui louent de
tout de tout de tout de tout et de tout
le monde quand je vois apparaître
quelqu'un que je ne connais pas c'est
comme c'est comme si j'avais faim
m'intéresse mais alors cette vie elle
vous apporter tout ce que vous en
attendiez donc vous allez je n'attends
rien je n'attendais rien et c'est
peut-être parce que je n'attendais rien
que tant de choses que sont arrivés je
n'ai pas fait grand chose pour attirer
ça
d'amour hoti je n'ai aucun regret je
n'ai aucun remords
je suis quelqu'un de très reconnaissant
quoique la vie et pu me faire de
douloureux j'ai eu des instants de
bonheur tellement fort
que je peux dire que merci
[Musique]